we've got a beautiful day out there our
friday is off to a wonderful start
temperatures are beautiful man it feels
like spring we've got a lot of 60s
around the valley because we only hit
the upper 80s yesterday
not much in the way of wind a little
breeze up there at kyle canyon
48 degrees at kyle canyon looking for
highs in the mid 70s
lee canyon at 69 today of course they're
open for their summer fun next week
they're going to be up
near 80 degrees oh mount charleston and
kyle kanye will be up near 90 as we get
the heat going
next week red rocks 93 today i want to
thank
our viewers for always sharing wonderful
pictures with us
like this one from rick he took this in
the lakes last night
as we saw the smoke from that sandy
valley fire
snaking through our skies and here is
that fire it's on the backside of mount
potency
off state route 160 1500 acres and i
just want to remind everybody that there
are
fire restrictions in our mountains all
on blm land and also out at lake mead
no campfires or charcoal stoves no open
flame torches
no fireworks and no steel core
ammunition or explosive targets
in the mountains it is way too dry and
out at lake mead the same smoking is in
enclosed vehicles only so just remember
lots of restrictive rules right now for
fires
and you've just got to be careful out
there because we're so dry
high pressure will continue to expand
out of mexico over the west
that's what's going to drive our
temperatures way up starting this
weekend and into next week 98 that's our
coolest day for the next eight
as we'll get into triple digits this
weekend breezy again on sunday
some clouds next week but it won't hold
back the heat we're looking at one
teens 112 114 115
and heat warnings all next week